et réactions il ya quelques minutes du
ministre de l'éducation gilles de robien
beaucoup de familles sont complètement
défaillante en termes de responsabilité
parentale la société doit régler son
problème de violence dit il depuis
longtemps les spécialistes cherche à
déceler les signes annonciateurs de la
délinquance il ya un peu plus d'un an
l'inserm l'institut de la santé et de la
recherche médicale avait mené une étude
sur les troubles de conduite des enfants
dès la maternelle à partir de trois ou
quatre ans une étude controversée saisi
du dossier le comité d'éthique fier de
rendre son avis c'est une mise en garde
explication josé blanc lapierre mathieu
dreujou au jardin d'enfants c'est un peu
comme dans la vie il y a ceux qui
subissent et ce qui frappe pour les
éducateurs ses colères son passage est
ce qu'il faut c'est surtout être
attentif peut très bien repéré qu'un
enfant étape systématiquement quand je
regarde un et de cette façon là on peut
se dire qu'il nous appelle
ils essayent de nous faire réagir c'est
un appel on prend soin aussi à ne tirer
au feu confusion sur son avenir
et encore moins prédire que parce qu'il
est agitée et qu'ils transgressent les
règles de vie à la crèche ou à l'école
il sera un futur délinquant or c'est
justement ce que conclut un rapport de
l'inserm l'année dernière vers 36 mois
on peut faire un premier repérage d'un
tempérament difficile est de proposer
d'inscrire dans le carnet de santé a
refusé d'obéir n'a pas de remords ne
change pas sa conduite
tollé général une pétition réunit
presque 200 mille signatures
les auteurs du rapport se défendent on
voit des enfants dépressifs des enfants
suicider en va des enfants en échec
scolaire et on se dit si on avait pu les
voir à 25 ans est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas
pu faire quelque chose aujourd'hui le
comité d'éthique condamne à son tour les
propos de l'inserm
il est porteur du jeu
de la violence dit les porter dans son
cerveau intrinsèquement d'une capacité à
exercer une délinquance futur et là nous
disons arrêtons ce qui est important
c'est l'environnement
le sujet est sensible le gouvernement
prépare actuellement une loi sur la
prévention de la délinquance
il devrait renoncer au dépistage des
trois ans